(whooshing)
(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans
like you.
(digital tones)
- I'm gonna give you a perspective,
a very brief perspective on
what I think is the topic today
from the vantage point of somebody
who is a clinical neurologist
and a research geneticist.
And so that's really
where I'm coming from.
And hopefully this idea of
a continuum will make sense
as I go through.
So two themes that I'd like to present
and discuss, human disorders of cognition
and behavior are part of
normal human variation,
in other words the human condition.
And to understand human brain function,
we must understand the
individual variability.
That's the key.
So from a geneticist's standpoint,
this says, for those
of you who can't read,
"Because my genetic
programming prevents me
"from stopping to ask
directions, that's why."
Now, so those of you who have been
in that situation before,
you can't blame your spouse.
This is genetic programming.
No, of course we know
that that's not true,
that behavior is a combination
of genes and the environment,
but genes play kind of a considerable role
in all of behavior as I'll
discuss really briefly
as well as brain structure and function,
which is what underlies our behavior.
It's the organ that is
essential for behavior.
So, neuropsychiatric disorders
are also highly heritable,
and so I'm just showing here
in A how prevalent many
of these disorders are,
even in the rarest like
Tourette's Syndrome
is close to a percent in the population.
Schizophrenia, about a percent.
Autism, a little more than a percent
all the way up to anxiety,
which is about 30% of general.
But if you look at the
calculated heritability,
which is just an estimate
from twin and family studies,
all of these disorders have
very substantial heritability.
And on some of them, the
error bars are quite large,
but they range...
None of them are less than 40%
and many of them are over 80%.
So we really have a group of
highly-heritable disorders
and the question is where
does that come from?
So, again, as a
neuroscientist and neurologist
as well as a geneticist, genes interact
with the environment during development
to lead to the cerebral structure.
Now, structure is not a static structure,
this is a very highly dynamic structure.
So we have what we can
see, what you can see
with imaging or other tools.
You have microscopic
anatomy, but you also have
chemical and molecular
plasticity that's ongoing
virtually constantly as you're listening
to this, it's ongoing.
So, and of course that is what
underlies cognitive function.
And of course it's not a unidirectional.
Development occurs over
time and cognitive function
and behavior feeds back
on brain structure,
so there's a constant
iteration of the brain
as we develop and as we're
exposed to the environment.
Now, of course, as we all look around,
we can see each other and
we're all highly variable.
We're all individuals.
We look at each other, we should
be able to tell each other
all apart from each
other most of the time.
And so the same thing with the brain.
There's an enormous amount
of variability in the brain,
and here is just one
example of that that I found
quite interesting from Lawrence Binder.
This is the IQ test, or
it's one of the IQ tests.
Forgive me, I'm not a psychologist,
so I'm just presenting this.
So this is from a paper that he did.
And basically, if you go
up to 11 or 14 sub-tests
on these different domains that make up IQ
and look at the percentage
of people who score,
these are normal people who
score in the abnormal range
on at least one test, it's 71.
And if you go to 14,
the more test 82% score
in the abnormal range.
And if you look at three
standard deviations,
which is really considerably...
Would be called abnormal in
psychoeducational testing,
it's almost a quarter when
you're doing 14 sub-tests.
So what does that mean?
We all have strengths and weaknesses.
We kind of know that, but
we don't act that way.
Our educational system
doesn't work that way
and a lot of times that we even
discuss our own colleagues,
we don't act that way.
So here's another point
is that if you look
at functional brain networks,
which are just kind of color-coded here,
things that are interconnected
with each other.
No brain area really acts alone,
they're connected in networks.
But if we look at a map of
inter-subject variability,
red being very high, we
can see that the areas
of highest inter-subject
variability are those areas
that are the most multi-modal,
called heteromodal association cortices,
these are not the
regions that are involved
in primary sensation like vision
or touch or motor function.
These are the places where thoughts come
and the environment is integrated.
So that's really a critical
issue is that the things,
like the frontal lobe and other circuits
that really make us who
we are allow us to plan
and really account for a lot
of our uniquely human characteristics
are the most variable between us.
And of course, I mentioned
there's a high degree
of variability, there's also
a high degree of heritability.
And this is, again, my genetics viewpoint.
Not deterministic, please
don't get that idea,
but there are two twins.
I just find this picture
so unbelievably cute.
Much cuter than the identical twin brains,
but the point here is
that identical twin brains
are also highly similar,
just like twins look similar
on the outside, the brain,
the structure, the function,
highly, highly similar.
In fact, most structures in the brain,
let's start with the cerebral cortex,
are around 70% to 80% heritability.
And this maintains over
the lifespan, actually,
so it's quite interesting.
So then the question is,
I showed you that IQ test
that shows that you might
have a really high IQ,
but the likelihood is
you're gonna be really poor
in a few areas.
And so let's explore that a little bit.
Is ability really uni-dimensional?
So the concept of g or
general intelligence.
This is highly heritable.
I think its heritability is around .6
and it's related to many
psychoeducational tests.
Again, as a neurologist,
not as a psychologist,
I look at it as things
that task working memory
and frontal lobe function very strongly,
but it doesn't predict many functions.
You can have a very high IQ
and be bad in certain things.
And therefore, again, just
like that Binder table
that I showed you, we
have to be really careful
when we're looking at people
to really understand strengths
and weaknesses which I
think is one of the themes
of the discussion that
we're gonna have today,
talking about very unusual strengths.
So ability is specific.
I'm just gonna hammer
this in a little bit.
This is, what I think, is
a spectacular chalk drawing
from somebody that I don't know well
but I've talked to his mother quite a bit
at some times who's an autistic artist
named Jonathan Lerman, who is
a really remarkable artist.
And the forward to this book is written
by The New York Times art critic.
This is a serious artist
and I have some of his art
and it's very Picasso-esque.
It's absolutely brilliant,
but there are times
when he's been absolutely non-verbal
and really highly dysfunctional
and having a lot of problems.
But, you know, this is not that uncommon.
Now, how about me?
You know, I'm a relatively smart guy.
I have a few degrees.
You know I'm not up there
with the people we're gonna
be talking about today.
I don't have any of those qualities.
I'm kind of not exceptional.
I'm just a professor, but I do...
No, seriously, there's
nothing exceptional about that
and yet at the same time,
I've had to do well in school
and that's because school
involves writing and reading
and mathematics and I can do that.
But this is one thing I can't do.
And this is not a joke.
That's my...
I've been drawing like that
since I was in 3rd or 4th grade.
This is the best I can do.
And I'm not joking.
Now it's true that
ability is a combination
of genes and the environment,
so there's no question
that I could probably do
better if I put my mind to it.
Bruce Miller believes that I can.
I've tried at times,
'cause my mom was an artist
and she tried to get me to drawing stuff
and I was really, really bad.
But just the point I want to make
is that strengths and weaknesses really...
Some strengths come
together, they come in groups
and we're gonna talk
about that a lot today,
but the point is just because
one's strong in one area
doesn't mean that you're
strong in all areas.
And if we had an educational system
where I had to represent the world
in two or three dimensions,
I wouldn't have gotten
very far, I'm sure of that.
So now how does this fit into genetics?
Well, this is from Wikimedia
Images, one of my main sources.
We use this a lot.
It's actually probably
from Daniel MacArthur.
You know, it's a cartoon
from the Broad Group,
but what you can see here
is this is 10,000 B.C.
This is around where we are right now.
This is the estimated
population in billions.
And you can see that
there is an enormous arise
that humans were a very small population.
But we essentially have arisen
from an ancestral population
more than 10,000 years ago.
What's interesting is that we come
from a small set of
ancestors, and that means
that we share a common genetic variation
that's been acted on by evolution.
If those had been very deleterious,
anything that's highly
deleterious would get removed
after thousands of generations.
So that the variation that we all share
that is common genetic variation,
things greater than 1% in the population,
our genomes are 99.9% identical.
Those things that we
share have been acted on
by natural selection to
remove strong bad actors,
and therefore the things that contribute
to most of our human phenotypes
from diabetes to human cognition,
each individually, have
very small effect sizes.
And so they haven't been purified.
And so when we're looking for
genes that cause diseases,
a lot of what's going on in
genetic association studies
is we're looking for relatively
high frequency variants
that are more than 1% in the population,
but they have very small effect sizes,
as opposed to mutation
screens that identify genes
of large effect, but they're
generally much rarer.
Now I'm not saying that
all human variation
is due to common variation,
but a good deal of it is.
And so we can begin to think,
and this is a classic behavior
from a behavior genetics textbook
from DeFries and Robert Plomin.
Actually, the W doesn't belong there.
There is part of my residual
dyslexia from childhood.
But complex diseases and disorders
in all complex human
cognition lies on a continuum
of normal variability, a
disease threshold model
where we get one copy
of each gene from mom
and one from dad, and
this particular variant,
if you have the BB variant, you're likely
to be past a threshold,
but it's not deterministic.
And think about this as an additive set
of normal distributions
where these variants
of very small effect sizes
are adding, adding, adding up.
Another point is that the threshold
is somewhat arbitrary in many cases.
What's high blood pressure?
What's high glucose?
What's bad reading?
What's attention deficit disorder?
Et cetera.
This is all somewhat
an arbitrary threshold
that's based upon
society and what usually,
hopefully, what's practical
for the biomedical enterprise.
So this is the kind of
foundation that took me
when I started to work on autism
now about 17 years ago
to think about autism
as part of the continuum
of normal variation.
And this is the idea.
Autism diagnosis depends
upon quantitative impairment
in multiple domains.
It's not qualitative.
We all...
Some people here are really
good socially, some aren't.
But to become autistic,
you have to fall out here.
If you think of each of these as a contour
of normal distribution where the green
is highly advantageous,
really superior functioning,
and the red is less than optimal.
And so they have for children with autism
have to have repetitive
restrictive behavior
and deficits in social behavior.
The diagnosis has changed
over the last five years
so that language is now not
fundamentally part of it
but it often is.
But just the point here is that, again,
a line is drawn, and you
have to have impairment
in multiple domains that's
quantitative and measured
so that those people that are here
who might be a sibling on one area
aren't autistic or if they're here.
And that's arbitrary again.
It's our diagnosis.
Do we have proof of that?
Yes, there's quite a bit of proof.
I'm gonna show you one
really nice piece of data
that was published recently by
Elise Robinson and Mark Daly.
So social function in those without autism
is strongly related to
the same genetic factors
that increase autism genetic risk.
What you can do is you can come up
with a compositive genetic score,
all these little small,
common risk variants,
add them up in what's called
a polygenic risk score.
And you can ask if I have that for autism,
and it has about a 70% prediction
for who's gonna be autistic, how well
is that correlated with just autism
in the normal population?
And the normal population being used here
is a longitudinal study of
parents and children in Avon.
It's in England.
It's called ALSPAC.
And if you look, you can see
that the genetic correlation
between the psychiatric
genetic consortium autism
and a Danish autism consortium
are both close to .3.
That's an enormous correlation.
So that's telling us that the things that
in the common variation that
we have that predisposes
to autism is part of normal variation.
So how about other things?
And you're gonna hear
a lot more about some
of these topics today,
but I just wanted to touch
on them and give you a point
of view, maybe a framework.
So there's something called synesthesia
and this is a slide from my colleague,
Simon Baron Cohen, who would've
given a much better talk
than I'm giving, and
unfortunately can't be here.
But stimulation of one
sensory modality automatically
triggers a perception in a second.
So it might be that when you see a word,
you hear music with it or vice versa,
when you hear music, there's
a color associated with it.
It's actually present in
some degree or another
in 4% of the population.
It also has a strong genetic...
There's evidence that
it has genetic factors.
So about almost 40% have at
least one other family member
with synesthesia, and
there's been some evidence
of genetic linkage, even, but no genes
have been identified as far as I'm aware,
but maybe Simon knows, or Simon Fisher.
So now I'm gonna tell you just a brief bit
about somebody that Simon
Baron Cohen knows quite well,
which is Daniel Tammet, and many of you
may have read his book,
Born on a Blue Day.
If you haven't read it, you must read it.
It is an extraordinary book.
If you haven't read it,
you wouldn't believe
that there's somebody who can do this.
But he sees numbers as shapes and colors.
This Test of Genuineness is a test
that is related to synesthesia.
He's invented his own language.
He learns languages in two weeks.
I think he learned Finnish in two weeks.
Perfectly.
He performs mathematical calculations
that you can't imagine.
He is the European
champion in pi, to 22,515.
And he has Asperger Syndrome.
So the question is...
So, okay, so that's an
interesting observation.
That's a very rare, unique
individual with these features.
So you can ask the question, does autism,
is synesthesia increased
in people with autism?
So if independent, synesthesia and autism
should co-occur in four
out of 10,000 people.
But they're not.
Simon Baron Cohen's study
shows that it's present
in almost 19%.
Of course, this is done via questionnaire.
So it would have to be
redone measuring it,
but I think one would argue
that it's quite enriched.
There's also an enrichment among those
who have perfect pitch with synesthesia.
In this study, about 20%.
So there's a relationship
of some of the things
that we're gonna be talking about today
that are really extraordinary variations
on the human mind, and a
common genetic variation,
and what we think of as intellectual
or behavioral disabilities or disorders.
And so I'll leave you with one thought.
What does it mean that a
feature that is present
rarely in the general population
is more frequent in those with a disorder?
I mean, of course it means
that the human condition
is one of strengths and weaknesses
and that great strength can be
the flip side of disability.
And in part, this is because
of the genetic contributions
to evolution, to human brain evolution.
That we've inherited strengths
along with weaknesses,
and sometimes they lead to
what we call a disorder.
And I'm gonna leave you with
another interesting thought,
that if you look at the
most variable brain regions
in human, there are also
those that have expanded most
on the human lineage,
getting back to one of my earliest slides.
Again, this is from a paper
Mueller et al in Neuron
in 2013, and basically if you look
at the cortical surface expansion in this
frontal parietal temporal lobe area
and then you look at the areas
with the most inter-subject
variability, there it is.
And we know that cortical surface volume,
especially volume, is highly heritable.
So that this variability is
highly heritable as well.
And you can look at this correlation.
There's a strong correlation throughout,
not just in my picture.
So we've had 150 years
in behavioral neurology
of learning from the individual,
from Tan who was Broca's first patient.
And from seeing two patients, he reasoned
that language was in the frontal lobes.
Well, maybe that was
a little too specific,
Wernicke helped him out a little bit.
But he reasoned that the cerebral cortex
was therefore asymmetric and that language
was on one side.
And here's another patient, Patient HM,
who was one of a series of patients
who had bilateral hippocampal damage
and played an important role
in our understanding of memory.
So again, I wanna say that we must learn
to continue to understand the nature
of individual differences and how disease,
what we call disease and
disorders, is really just part
of the human condition.
And these exceptional variations
are often strongly associated
with vulnerabilities.
Thank you.
(applause)
(pleasant digital tones)